thank you all for coming to what is the
second in our series called the big
picture being sponsored by the brady
johnson program in grant strategy my
name is Beverly gage I'm the director of
that program and I am a professor here
in the history department I'm delighted
to welcome Kim Phillips fine and max
boot who I will introduce in a little
more detail in a moment for this
discussion of an issue that is really
critical to the politics of our time as
well as the politics of the past and the
future as the title suggests American
conservatism past present and future I
want to say a few words about this
series itself and the idea behind this
particular format and the way that we
try to frame our conversations in the
ground strategy program we try to do a
couple of things that are a little bit
different I think from what often
happens on the rest of the Yale campus
the first of those is to bring different
forms of knowledge together so to build
conversations between people who are
primarily working within the Academy
within universities often historians
with people who are engaging those same
sorts of questions from outside of the
university setting and have everybody
sort of sit down together and try to
hash some issues through so we're going
to have really a moderated conversation
today I'll be asking some questions up
here but it's going to be mostly a
conversation between our two guests and
then we'll open it up for group
discussion after about 45 minutes or so
so we try to as I said kind of combine
different forms of knowledge around big
questions and that's really the second
set of ideas behind this series which is
that often we are either focused very
narrowly on particular forms of
expertise that universities are very
good at doing people coming in to give
talks about their area of research and
on the other hand I think we're often
sort of caught up in a very rapidly
changing news cycle at the moment and
the
conversations are really designed to
step back a little bit from both of
those and try to ask some really big
questions in a broad historical
perspective in this case of course we're
going to be talking about the sort of
long history of American conservatism
and where it's headed and then the last
thing that we like to try to do in these
conversations is to think a little bit
about the word strategy which is to
think about how political actors in this
case the conservative movement have said
about changing American politics
political culture sometimes we deal with
that in the foreign policy context so
really to ask questions of how it is
that people have conceived of exerting
influence and in particular political
influence in the world and to think
about what we all might learn from that
ourselves so that's my idea of what
we're going to be doing in this
conversation but of course I will mostly
be focused on what comes from our two
distinguished guests Kim Phillips fine
and max booth let me just take a moment
to introduce them and then to welcome
them to the stage Kim Phillips fine is a
professor of history American history at
New York University and she is the
author of one of the true classics at
this point in the history of American
conservatism a book called invisible
hands the making of the conservative
movement from the New Deal to Reagan
that book really looks particularly at
the rise of organized business in
politics at the rise of free market
ideas as they were shaped from the 1930s
up to the 1980s and while it has a real
intellectual history component to it
it's also about the ways in which those
ideas and those coalition's began to
reshape American politics more broadly
through coalition's that came to be
known as the modern conservative
movement more recently she is the author
of fear city
is a book about the New York City fiscal
crisis of the 1970s and the ways in
which that moment began to shape sort of
a new form of urban austerity politics
in the United States that book was a
finalist for the Pulitzer Prize in
history and she has won many other
awards and accolades over the year
she is also a prominent public historian
who has written very widely for
publications ranging from the nation to
the New Republic to Harper's Magazine on
a wide array of topics max boot is
currently the Jeanne Kirkpatrick fellow
in international security or in national
security
at the Council on Foreign Relations he
is also a historian I should note a Yale
trained historian someone who spent one
year here in the Yale history graduate
program before deciding that he was
going to actually leave the Academy I
think we drove him out and on to maybe
bigger and better things in some sense
after getting his master's degree in
history he moved into journalism worked
for several years at the Christian
Science Monitor and then as the IDI
editor of The Wall Street Journal for
several years now as I said he is at the
Council on Foreign Relations and
throughout this period of time he's
written several books one of which the
students in the ground strategy class
have already encountered which is
invisible armies it's a study of
guerrilla warfare and terrorism in a
very very broad historical perspective
the book that we're going to spend some
time talking about today is more recent
it's called the corrosion of
conservatism why I left the right so at
this point I think max boot is one of
the country's most prominent never Trump
errs someone who spent much of his life
and formative intellectual and political
experiences within the conservative
movement and since 2016 has left and we
can talk about whether he is still
calling himself a conservative these
days and exactly
he might fit into politics in this
moment I should note that he has also
been widely engaged as a foreign policy
analyst and as a political adviser most
notably to the McCain and Romney and
Rubio presidential campaigns and he's
also worked a great deal in Iraq and
Afghanistan as an adviser to to various
military figures thinking about the role
of u.s. foreign policy and US military
power in particular so please join me in
welcoming both Kim Phillips fine and max
boot to the stage for what will be a
fascinating conversation all right well
welcome I thought it might be useful as
we start this conversation about
American conservatism to define a few
terms and starting out because I think
the parameters of that title are not
self-evident so I wondered if we could
maybe just start out with your
reflections both on how you think about
this term conservatism in the present
but also this category known as the
conservative movement and maybe offer a
few reflections and starting out for the
audience about where you're starting and
thinking about those terms their history
your own experiences in them I thought
maybe we'd start with with you max well
first thanks for having me always great
to be back at Yale and i absolve yell of
any blame for the course that my life
was taken having only been here for a
year but it was a great year and it
forged some some relationships and
friendships that have lasted to this day
you know this is actually sort of a new
thing for me to think about even though
I was quote-unquote part of the
conservative movement for you know
pretty much my whole adult life I've all
you know I intellectually I've been
focused on other matters as a military
historian foreign policy walk so I have
not actually I did not in the past
the kind of intensive study of the
conservative political movement for
example that Kim has done it for me it
was kind of a thing that I lived rather
than then studied but I and I don't
think there's any real agreement on what
American conservatism is all about it's
a fairly arbitrary term and that in many
parts of the world would actually be
called classical liberalism or at least
the kind let me step at least the kind
of conservatism that I espoused and to
some extent still espouse would be
called classical liberalism in other
parts of the world because it's
basically dedicated to enhancing
individual liberty and it believes in
trying to minimize to the extent
possible the role of the state
encouraging free enterprise along of
course with a healthy social safety net
in the American context that's also a I
believe set that that's that for strong
defense American leadership in the world
respect for a kind of middle class
morality as that morality has shifted
over the years suspicion of vast social
engineering suspicion that the
government can remake society as a force
for good so again you know largely what
has been known elsewhere in the world as
liberalism in fact is what has become
known as conservatism but I guess what's
happened in the last few years and I
don't want to jump the gun on the story
but I think what's happened is that
American conservatism is being redefined
in terms very similar to the kind that
you've seen in other parts of the world
where conservatism has really meant
blood and soil ideology and essentially
nativism and nationalism and true
you know conservatism in the sense of
being really reactionary and hostile to
immigrants which for example the
conservatism that I grew up with was not
hostile damn against Ronald Reagan for
example it was very welcoming of
immigrants and he was somebody who was
president when I was growing up in the
1980s and now I feel like President
Trump and his followers are tapping into
a different strain of American
conservatism that was always of or at
least not always but generally a fairly
marginal one that I associate with Fig
like father Coughlin or John Calhoun
Charles Lindbergh George Wallace people
that I view as being disreputable
racists and and reactionaries and and I
feel like the modern conservative
movement as it developed in the 50s and
60s
what's the summit an attempt to to
define conservatism in a kind of
different classical liberal kind of way
well it's still incorporating people who
hold some of these belief systems but I
think what's happened now is that you've
seen a redefinition of conservatism so
that's really this kind of nationalist
populist european-style conservative
strain which is becoming dominant in the
United States and people like me who
still hew to a kind of classical liberal
outlook on the world I think are very
much marginalized in the Republican
Party which is why I'm not a Republican
anymore
great well Kim Phillips fine does that
make sense as a description of the
conservative movement well it was
actually saying I know remarks they
brought to mind a essay by Friedrich von
Hayek in maybe 1958 or so called why I
am I why I am NOT a conservative or
something like that and Hayek also Hayek
was a an economist and book the Road to
Serfdom and who is you know was cited by
many later participants in the
conservative movement as the kind of one
of the and by including by Reagan
himself as sort of one of the architects
of their intellectual creed and Hayek
also really did not want him to find
selves too conservative not exactly for
the same reasons but that's as a sense
that he also took the phrase classical
liberal would have to want to be a wig
but that never caught off anybody so so
but but all but but thinking that
conservative wasn't the right word
because conservative connotes you know
an adherence to tradition a shoring up
of older hierarchies a belief and kind
of the stable desire to preserve the
stable communities of the past I mean
again it in a very
you know kind of idealistic sent that
was what the word conservative meant for
him and he wanted to associate himself
more with the forces of capitalism of
modernity of transformation and
spontaneity and a faith in a sense of an
open future so anyway just interesting
that that your comment kind of brought
that that to mind I think the idea
welcome what is the conservative you
know what is conservatism is maybe a
little different than what is the
conservative movement and I think the
conservative movement in American
politics it's is maybe a it's
interesting we're maybe standing at a
moment when that movement you can kind
of trace it a clear arc that it followed
which is coming perhaps to an end or at
least a transformation so deep that it's
not the same any longer I think the
conservative movement as we think of it
kind of has its roots I would say in the
in the 1930s and the period afterward
and it's kind of a reaction to the rise
of liberalism and of a liberal a kind of
the New Deal liberalism not exactly
classical liberalism but kind of New
Deal liberalism and the idea of the kind
of that the the the idea of an expanded
state and expanded government and
expanded social safety net that
individual freedom and prosperity
depends in some way on the present
preserve preservation of material
security through that the rise labor
movement at that time and that in a way
modern conservatism took shape in
reaction to that and the conservative
movement grew out of a long moment of
reaction to that in one way or another
and yeah I think it's an interesting I
would think many of those institutions
and in certain ways the the central
Creed is now coming into you know under
under pressure I mean the conservative
movement brought together and they're
kind of famously brought together
different strands on the one hand a
faith in the free market a kind of set
of ideas about it has a strong religious
or evangelical at certain points
component to the movement and also
anti-communism linking these together
and it's always had these very these
component his wings that were at odds
with each other the how they have hung
together is you know been of great
interest in fascination through the
years and but but I think at this point
there may be there's a way in which
things are changing I would agree and
the movement as it existed previously is
is changing its shape so well I'm
interested that both of you sort of
answered that question really through an
assessment of ideas and intellectual
life one of the pieces of your book that
was so interesting to me was the
description of your own from a very
young age so I believe that you were you
know nerdily reading national review and
what twelve something on this order
nobody would lie about no one would brag
about that unless it were true and your
description of a kind of intellectual
awakening that took place through that
kind of reading through engagement with
figures like Hayek etc and it seems to
me that one of the things that
conservatives at least a certain form of
conservative politics in the 70s and
then the 80s was very proud of was
having sort of become and then the
Republican Party itself having become a
party of ideas right there was a moment
I think many liberals and many left is
certainly disagreed with this but in
which the Republican Party was claiming
that it was the party of ideas the
conservative movement particularly a
kind of elite intellectual conservative
movement prided itself on a certain form
of deep intellectual engagement and
intellectual combat so I'm wondering if
you can reflect a little bit about
through your own experiences in that and
then how we make sense of what's
happened in this moment which is not
just that the politics have changed but
that the I think the level of respect
accorded to people who say learn about
foreign policy or engage in these kind
of broad intellectual endeavors seems to
not have much of a place in conservatism
and particularly but maybe in politics
more broadly well I would say if you
want to disprove the theory of evolution
all you have to do is look at at the
transformation of conservative
communicators from William F Buckley Jr
to Sean Hannity I mean that is you know
idiot ah Christian action that is a the
dumbing down of America and I came of
age in the 1980s when my heroes and
again revealing what a nerd I I wasn't
am my heroes were folks like Bill
Buckley and and George Will who were
tremendously are you died and who
espoused this this very learned form of
conservatism and that was a moment
remember when you had intellectuals like
Jean Kirkpatrick and Bill Bennett and
others serving in high positions in the
Reagan administration and that was
briefly a moment when the Republican
Party of these thought of itself that is
a party of ideas and wanted you know I
was an undergrad at Berkeley and one of
the things that that revolted me at
Berkeley so to speak about the campus
left was that I felt that they were
intolerant of competing ideas they
didn't want to engage in debate they
wanted to bully and I remember I mean I
wrote a a conservative column for the
for the student newspaper that Daily
Californian I remember I once got a
bullet in the mail that had my name on
it literally had my name taped on it so
I was not cowed by that I was in fact
they kind of confirmed my view that the
people on the other side were not
interested in a real debate they were
just interested in intimidation and
sadly I think what's happened in the
years since I mean there's still a lot
of people I think on the Left who are
not interested in debate or interested
in intimidation want to shut down free
speech I mean you've had some of those
controversies here at yeah but I think
what's happened in in the year sense is
that the biggest threat to free speech
and the biggest enemy of rationality and
free debate has become the Republican
Party and the right wing in America I
hesitate to call it a conservative
movement
but certainly the right-wing witch and I
think this is something that really
dates back to the 1990s actually one of
the most fateful decisions the Reagan
administration made and I think in
hindsight one of the worst was the FCC
decision to stop enforcing the Fairness
Doctrine which made it possible for the
rise of Rush Limbaugh Fox News Channel
and then of course at the same time you
had the rise of Newt Gingrich and the
bomb throwers in Congress and you know I
was very naive at the time and I imagine
that these were positive developments
that all these forces would spread
conservative ideas but in fact they're
not spreading conservatism what they are
spreading is this all-encompassing rage
this desire to attack you know liberals
with no almost no positive agenda but to
the extent that they have one it's
actually kind of a nationalist populist
racist anti-immigrant type of agenda
harking back to some you know imagined
paradise of the 1950s where white people
ran the country basically and that's you
know that to the extent that there's an
ideological agenda that's it but most of
the time I mean I'm giving him too much
credit I mean this I mean if you look at
like what people like Tucker Carlson my
dear friend on Fox News Channel says I
mean I think that's kind of the
underlying basis of what he says and
does but in fact what he says and does
is just a clown show
it's basically insults for the sake of
insults and you know Donald Trump is in
many ways the perfect personification of
that kind of high decibel low IQ form of
of conservatism which is now the
dominant a political force in this
country where he just I mean he is
literally irrational he doesn't make
sense from sentence to sentence but he
channels this kind of rage of his
followers and of course Fox News Channel
with the Hannity's and ingre hams and
Tucker Carlson's and others they do the
same and so it's it's this all in
kampala this hostility towards expertise
towards evidence towards reason the only
thing that really counts as attitudes
and name-calling and this is really the
destruction I think of intellectual
conservativism in America
and what what makes this destruction
final is that there are so few
conservatives who are willing to stand
up against these trends and so many of
my friends on the right have basically
had their brains sucked out and replaced
with trumpian mush they have become
enablers of the worst trends in American
life and this has been shocking him even
people who purported to be intellectuals
are now revealing themselves to be you
know nothing but I can't fall over as it
will justify any kind of excess or
ideology in the name of seeking
political powers so this is to me has
been a very troubling development which
you know exposes some very uncomfortable
truths about this movement that I was
part of in the past I do think that
there were higher aspirations and some
people still try to keep to them I mean
there is still a very small cadre of
nevertrump conservatives but it's it's I
mean I think what's happened in the
conservative movement intellectually in
their rejection of science and reason I
for example you know I just point out
hey guys there's not really a global
warming debate okay it's an established
fact you can argue about what to do
about it you can't really deny that it
exists and yet a huge portion of the
Republican Party in the conservative
movement does deny global warming led of
course by Donald Trump who thinks it's a
Chinese ho so this kind of really just
irrationalism which has taken root on
the right I think is is deeply shocking
to somebody like me who grew up in the
1980s when as I said before the
Republican Party was purportedly the
party of ideas so do you have
reflections on this kind of narrative
that there was this Golden Age of kind
of Republican ideas that we've fallen
off from or are there places that we
should look to in history that might
help explain some of the forces that
we're now seeing emerge I mean are we at
a moment of break two things so one is
that and I think actually I think
historians have been coming back to
these questions as well from a different
perspective a lot of historians have
written about the conservative movement
and the development of the ideas the
institution's relationship with the
Republican Party but I think and we see
years there's been a desire to pull back
and look at their I think they know that
this the conservative movement is sort
of one strand of a much broader
conservative or right leaning or
right-wing community in the political
community in in American history and so
and and there have always been these I
think you know there's been the the
coffins the kind of presence of American
Nazis and fascists during the 30s
McCarthyism the massive resistance the
the the anti-abortion politics there's a
long and there's a long huge world of
people who have been who have whose
politics have been animated more by the
this kind of rage than by the sort of
the ideas of Hayek for example there's a
an end by by by Rage by racism by a
desire to maintain various kinds of
traditional hierarchies and and so it's
a much broader universe in a way and and
the the conservative movement you know
has a relationship to this and I think
actually it's not you know the the a lot
of the histories of the right have
focused for example on the moment when
William F Buckley in the National Review
distances itself from the american
mercury which was an anti-semitic
publication and fifties or the moment
when buckley you know kind of writes out
the John Birch Society but what and I
wanted historians and focus on those
moments is kind of a break between the
respectable right and the sort of the
right-wing crazies out there or
something like that but in fact I think
a lot of you know in there's been the
the is what matters that there was that
break does it matter that there were you
know tens of thousands of people who
were supporters in the John Birch
Society and that their activism then
helps to propel the Goldwater campaign
in 1960 and then again in 1964 and so
where do you place the emphasis is it
more on the mainstreaming of the
movement or is not the existence of this
broader universe of people the kind of
the unrespectable right or something
like that whose ideas and attitudes may
not be either also or not just contain
to movement participants or activists
but actually ramify outward into the
broader population in different ways and
so I think that's one way of looking at
it I think another you know I think
there is also and I guess my you know my
work which is partly been on these
business conservatives has is a
different lineage for trumpism
that there's an another I would say
there are ways in which Trump's politics
you know they in certain ways they break
from precepts of the movement
conservatism around free trade for
example but in other ways they actually
build on themes that were long present
and and I'm not even getting to the
anti-immigrant politics which we can
talk about more but but but just things
like the kind of veneration of private
enterprise or the veneration of the
figure of the businessman and the sense
that you know that the private sector is
sort of automatically and reflexively
better than the public sector and the
kind of anti-tax politics and that there
are certain ways in which Trump's own
you know somewhat ridiculous celebration
so it was a genius of business you know
Jesus businessman and executive it taps
into this much you know the set of ideas
that are connected to things that have
been long promoted by parts of the
conservative movement and also by you
know the ways in which that movement is
grown out of business support so I think
that it's not I think you have it's it's
you know while there are ways in which
Trump does you know it has has rejected
the contrition all conservative movement
institutions and parts of the ideology
there are other ways in which he you
know builds on and is kind of made
possible by this long history so
I could just pick up on a point that Kim
just made I think there's there's a lot
of truth in that and I think what you're
getting at is that I think people like
me you were part of the conservative
movement tended to think that the
conservative movement was the whole of
the American writer by which we meant of
course the conservative intellectual
movement the work that folks like me
were doing at or at the American
Enterprise Institute or what-have-you
National Review at cetera and I think
what you're right I think this is
something this is really maybe an
obvious point but one that I really had
not gone up and brought home to me until
Trump's election which was to understand
how divorced you know conservative
intellectuals were from the actual
concerns of most people who identify
with conservatism or the Republican
Party because you know I feel like
basically a lot of what liberals have
been saying for a long time is that a
lot of people are voting for the
Republican Party because they're racist
and they want to see a racist agenda and
that was something that I resisted for a
long time because I would say hey I'm
not a racist my friends aren't a racist
aren't racist you know what what are you
talking about and you know we've gone
from the Republican Party you know dog
whistling to racists to wolf whistling
and I mean the appeal is just so clear
in overwhelming in Trump's case that I
really can't deny the reality and what
this is making me realize is that you
know I really did not understand the
Republican electorate because I thought
that they actually like conservative
principles but I think what the 2016
election shows in the way you know that
Trump ran the 2018 election is that for
a lot of people the racism was really in
the xenophobia was really what they were
looking for and in some ways Trump is a
truer expression of the American right
than people like you know John McCain or
Mitt Romney which is why I think a lot
of the reason why there's actually much
more enthusiasm in the Republican ranks
for Trump than there is in many ways for
people right like McCain and Romney who
whatever you may think of their politics
were good people are good people well it
makes me sort of thinking historically
going back to a moment like the 1964
election was just a moment when Barry
goal
Waters campaigns are the first
identifiably conservative candidate runs
on the Republican ticket someone who's a
proud conservative who considers himself
to the degree that this was the
terminology of that moment a kind of
movement conservative we have one story
that is about this new sort of free
market libertarian coalition that's
beginning to build that is movement
conservatism of course the other thing
that happens in 1964 is that the states
that go for Barry Goldwater are the
states of the deep south right nobody
else in his home state nobody else votes
for for Barry Goldwater so there's been
an electoral coalition that has been
built over many many decades that has
seemed to me always to be something of
an uneasy electoral coalition maybe an
electoral coalition that was organized
around a kind of anti statist politics
that people could come in to from
various perspectives so if you are anti
civil rights you're sort of focused on
restraining federal power in that way
particularly around questions of race if
you're a business conservative you're
concerned with restraining the
regulatory state if you're an
ideological libertarian you have your
own ideas about that if you're a
religious conservative again sort of
you're focused on keeping the federal
government out of local public schools
resisting Zoar federal Supreme Court
decisions so this has been I guess what
I'm saying it seems like this has been
an uneasy coalition for a very long time
it maybe had a certain organizing logic
particularly in on in the Cold War but
maybe even since then and I guess my big
question is are we at a moment when that
is breaking down are we about to see
some realignment of the political
parties and the kind of political
coalition's that have operated in the
United States I guess it's kind of a
question of what happens to the max
boots of the world now in terms of
institutional and party politics but are
we are we at an actual realignment
moment is are we
seeing parties become fundamentally
identified differently than they have
been sort of I guess since really the
the 1960s certainly the 1970s I don't
know maybe Kimmy want to stir it on that
well I guess I would actually just dial
back for one minute just to what you
were saying about the 1964 election and
I guess is another and I would just be I
actually traced back to hear your
thoughts about this or about the
nineties for election and Goldwater in
particular but I think you know it just
is so hard it I think it's always very
hard in the history right surprised
these things apart because Goldwater
here we have this candidate conscience
of a conservative his 1960 book ghost
written by Plymouth luckily his
brother-in-law
but the book is negocio it see Goldwater
identify is it's his book and it's this
hit on college campuses is it both kind
of helps to build the idea of the book
was actually originally financed by
business people who were going to sell
it to their you know to buy it and mass
and give it to their managers and
workers but it becomes a hit on college
campuses as well and the book both is a
you know on the one hand it is you know
it's this this impact that hold the
statement of it is meant to be via kind
of taking conservatism away from being a
politics of privilege to one of
conscience and the introduction to the
book is very defensive about this or
kind of saying it's not this is people
have said conservatives it's the
politics of the rich but actually this
is a moral principle position and it
stands for this is that it's about
freedom it's a it's a politics of
freedom of liberation in some way it's
kind of taking the language and promises
of the left and associating them with
you know being a conservative so it's a
it's which is that the project of the
book at the same time a big part of that
book is about states rights it's up the
expresses Goldwater is opposition to
Brown versus Board of Education his
sense that any kind of action on the
part of our government to desegregate
schools is kind of overstepping the
constitutional bounds he personally it's
not a post integration but he is opposed
to and he expresses off
to any kind of national civil rights law
which is then how he'll vote in later
years as well as to brown it's okay from
the outset it's this politics which is
pretty explicit about appealing to
people who don't want to do anything to
oppose southern segregation and that's
part of how that electoral coalition is
built those are the states that go for
Goldwater and I think there's a and then
there are other ways in which you could
look at this connection between the kind
of politics of race and racism and the
ideas about the free market but I think
even in Goldwater's and and then in in
that actual campaign one of the you know
the the Goldwater winds up running you
know a certain amount of the the you
know the in the rhetoric of
individualism gives way to a discussion
of law and order in the context of 1964
and the kind of uprisings of that year
and growing civil rights movement there
the discussion of law and order is very
clearly about black protest and finding
ways to shut it down and so I just think
there's a you know that these these
politics have always been joined more
deeply so I don't you know I think the
question are we added a realignment
point what is going to happen I mean I
think it's as a historian it's you know
we're projecting through I think the
whole there are a lot of ways in which
though it does seem yeah I think yeah
there's this this it's not just the
Republican Party also there's the story
of what's happening within the
Democratic Party and a the all the
struggles taking place there so I think
this does it does this it is not an
accident that if this would be a moment
of reckoning and kind of and thinking
about the future I think nobody is
really sure what will happen and as a
historian - it's you're you're yeah it
is a kind of really sharp readjustment
it's harder I think to write about the
right than it was for me when I started
down this path you know though many
years ago what's gonna happen to the max
boots of the world well just to back up
a second I mean I agree
what Kim said about the goldwater in the
64 election and that was really I write
about that in my book the corrosion of
conservatism and I've managed to
alienate a lot of a lot of conservatives
and Republicans because you know I I
don't look at Trump as being this this
strange creature who came out of nowhere
to take over the Republican Party I do
think what he's doing and saying does
have real roots in the Republican Party
although again I don't think it's to
find the totality the Republican Party
but it has been a significant strain and
I and I do go back in the book to 64 and
say that was really the moment when the
Republican Party went from being the
party of Lincoln to being the party of
the segregationist and that actually
prefigured the Richard Nixon Southern
Strategy in a lot of ways Republicans
would prefer to put it on Nixon and his
Southern Strategy because Nixon as we
know it was kind of an immoral
disreputable figure but not when fact
this actually started with Barry
Goldwater who remains today an icon of
American conservatism now I think what
makes it a little more complicated is
the fact that I don't actually think and
I I'm ready to be corrected but as far
as I know I don't actually think Barry
Goldwater or Ronald Reagan who roasts
the political Fame supporting Barry
Goldwater with the speech in 1964 I
don't think Reagan and Goldwater were
actually racist I mean Goldwater was
somebody who actually integrated Arizona
National Guard you know Reagan always
told the story about how he had you know
black classmates who were on the
football team at Eureka College and how
he took them into his own home and they
would not be allowed to stay at a
segregated hotel and I don't I mean just
reading like Reagan's correspondents and
so forth and writings I don't really see
any evidence of explicit racism but I do
think that ever since 1964 Republicans
have been flirting with racism and often
using kind of the dog whistle
terminology about states rights welfare
queens law and order that kind of stuff
and I think to some extent I would say
largely my sense is that people like
like Goldwater and Reagan probably did
so somewhat innocently because they
actually believed in states rights are
they actually believed in limiting the
role of federal government because they
believed in private
prai's and so forth but I think there is
also a much more explicitly racial wing
of southerners Rayleigh people like
strong Thurmond and Jesse Helms
literally I mean they knew what they
were doing they for them this was all
about race and keeping African Americans
down and I think they basically formed
an unholy alliance and that's what made
possible the rise of the modern
Republican Party at which in many ways
you could argue I mean
oversimplification but kind of an
alliance between Midwestern
isolationists and southern
segregationists and then on top kind of
the whipped cream the top the the sundae
there was a small amount of intellectual
stuff that the people like me or Bill
Buckley or others generated but I think
this was you know to use kind of marxist
terminology this was you know this was
the the the kind of the the structure
upon which the party was constructed and
obviously as Ken points out there was
also a lot of business interests with
money favoring deregulation and so forth
but in terms of coming back to you know
your question about where do we go from
here is there a real and I think there
is a potential realigning moment you saw
that in 2018 when you had Republican
suburbs across the country voting for
Democratic candidates and Republicans
lost 40 seats in the house because they
really lost the center-right voters
especially women in all these suburban
districts and now staggering to see that
Orange County the the hotbed of
conservatism now has an entirely
Democratic representation in Congress
for the first time you know since the
1930s or something like that so you know
something is clearly going on here I
think there is an opportunity here and I
hope my fear is that you know as Abba
Eban said of the Palestinians they never
miss an opportunity to miss an
opportunity
I fear that Democrats never miss an
opportunity to miss an opportunity
although I think that they were actually
pretty smart in 2018 and I hope they
will be smart going forward and that
they will choose somebody who is
reasonably centrist ie not Bernie
somebody who can actually appeal to the
great middle and bring over all these
disaffected middle the road independ
in some former Republicans like me you
can't stand the direction of the
Republican Party I think there is the
potential for a massive realigning
election right now if Democrats can pull
that off but obviously too soon to say
if that's actually going to happen well
I want to give you a chance to reflect
on some of that but I also want to look
back and think about in this moment
right so there are realignments in
politics and big structural forces that
are often at play demographics the
economy but then there's also strategy
there are people who set out
deliberately to kind of remake the
political landscape and so I wonder if
you have reflections on kind of
conservatism as a movement which took
what many people have described this
period from the 30s through say the
1970s as kind of the great age of
liberalism in American politics and then
proceeded to I think quite
self-consciously transform where
political power sat transform what did
the American political culture was like
so are there are there lessons to be
learned from that sort how did that
happen is it just big structural forces
are there moments of strategy and kind
of deliberate intervention that would be
useful to think about no matter where
you are on the on the political spectrum
right now yeah I think I think I think
it's actually it's the the conservative
mobilization has a there were many ways
in which I think conservative activists
were very self-conscious about strategy
and particularly and though this may
sound more it makes sound more
Machiavellian or something that I
intended you guys I didn't know way in
which I'm not and I know Machiavelli is
a you know a grand strategy figure but I
think there's a a a way in which I think
that a lot of conservative actors were
very self-aware about building
meant that that they felt was not the
movement of the majority or that they
were building a politics especially
actually in this kind of moment in the
50s 60s 70s that that they were aware or
that they thought was not one that the
the broad population of the country was
easily or automatically drawn to and so
there was a strong effort or strong
interest in finding ways to they might
have had a sense that you know if people
only really understood who we were up to
of course they would come along and
agree but but also a sense that what
they were doing was a minority a
minority mobilization at the time and
they had to find a way to win in
hearings and converts and I guess there
are a couple of so there's a very deep
interest actually in building a politics
of of ideas I think the idea of the
right as a place of ideas it's not an
accident I think there was actually a
lot of effort energy and intensity put
into building intellectual institutions
and funding and sort of creating a
conservative intellectual Network and
you know you see this both in you know
youth of course you see this in law
schools through the federal society you
see it in the networks of think tanks
and and all the different kinds of think
tanks and sort of the efforts to bring
young people into those and and summer
programs and institutes there's a whole
world of kind of generating an
intellectual infrastructure for the
right there's also a you know kind of
effort to counter the to try to build
the Institute you're kind of to counter
liberal leaning institutions like labor
unions or to kind of campaign against
them actively in the
workplace in different ways so again
kind of creating the sense of a a
groundswell or sort of attack these
institutions at the root the interest in
the court it's also an effort to find a
way to influence policy but without
actually having to build a majority in
support of the mobilization so I think
there it there had I think these kinds
of no efforts are actually now quite
strategic quite careful and quite you
know they're they involve a level of
conscious planning I think I do actually
think that there is a way in which
movements of the left are kind of in her
have a certain kind of structural
difference or that politics that are
based in one way or another in kind of
challenging society as it is or
tradition or sort of social hierarchies
as they are that those politics are
harder to craft and you you can't really
do them simply from above they demand a
kind of effort to mobilize the broad
mass of the citizenry the population and
bring them into political life in one
way or another and there is no other
basis for their strength over time so
while I think you know there's a lot of
elements of you know kind of building
ideas and you know creating more
intellectual networks and those matter
but at the heart I think there is this
this kind of structural difference in
how these mobilizations can you know
hope to be victorious and I think hoped
it and I'm victorious is too simple but
sit hope to change things in the future
or hope to build a different kind of
future and I you know I guess I would
say that something of the same is true
today so well I wonder if you want to
take that up and maybe also bring in a
subject and this will be my last
question then we'll open it up to the
floor also think about where your
foreign policy work sort of fits into
anything we've had a very domestic
politics focused discussion here so
either thinking about strategy or just
thinking about the ways in which sort of
in your own experience those two realms
have interacted and are we seeing a
divergence between kind of domestic and
foreign policy now or are we are we
seeing them both move in a dramatically
new direction well I think what the
trumpian
ascendancy is revealing is I think how
unimportant so much of this intellectual
work that was done by the conservative
movement in the past actually was and I
think there was a tendency to exaggerate
its importance in part by people like me
who are actually doing this work but
also by people on the Left who said oh
look at all these people on the right
they're doing all this they're funding
all these think tanks they're doing all
this thinking we got to do the same
thing and at the end of the day I think
you know the only thing that really
matters is kind of this brood struggle
I mean I'm exaggerating this kind of
struggle for power it's not the only
thing that matters but it matters more I
think in many ways than most of the
ideas because I mean I think what you're
seeing is you know you're seeing the
Republican Party losing any allegiance
to most of the ideas that supposedly
define the Republican Party in the
modern era I mean this is supposedly the
party of law and order which supports a
president who daily attacks the FBI and
the Justice Department this is
supposedly the party of free trade who
supports a president who has launched
trade wars with every American trading
partner this is supposedly the party of
fiscal responsibility that supports a
president who was out of two trillion
dollars in debt since he came into
office this is supposedly the party of
traditional morality that supports a
president who pays off his pornstar
mistress and a Playboy Playmate so
anything that I would recognize as it
being tradition almost anything I would
recognize the key word is almost
anything that recognizes traditional
conservatism has been happily jettisoned
in this pell-mell rush to seize power
the only two things that really remain I
would say of the traditional oh I would
add also sorry you raised the issue of
foreign policy and also of course a
Republican commitment suppose that
American commitment to American global
leadership and and defense you know has
been jettisoned to support a president
who regularly trashes our allies and
kisses up to our enemies I mean I came
of age when Ronald Reagan was saying mr.
Gorbachev tear down this wall so it's
it's disorienting for me to see a
Republican president who is now saying
you know mr. Putin is very strong and
convincing in his denials that's quite a
change and so all these traditional
Republican ideas have been jettison and
so what's left I think basically two
things one a commitment to lower taxes
no matter what and a commitment to a
point right-wing judges and the reason
why right-wing judges are important is
because that is basically how the the
evangelicals think they are going to
outlaw abortion and gay marriage and
they claim to believe in
constitutionalism of course they do no
such thing and you've seen the shocking
spectacle in the last week or so of in
the house only 13 Republicans voted to
overturn Donald Trump's unconstitutional
state of emergency to appropriate money
that has not been actually voted by
Congress in it that's as clear a
violation of the Constitution as you can
imagine and yet the party of
constitutional conservatism has endorsed
that and they will endorse it in the
Senate as well
and yet they want to see conservative
judges because they're not interested in
the Constitution what they're interested
in is basically this very thing that
they accuse liberals of doing which is
legislating their agenda from the bench
so yes they want to legislate their
social agenda from the bench and they
want to cut taxes and you know cutting
really a sign of how brain-dead the
Republican Party is is that it has
become the party of cutting taxes that
no matter what and no matter what the
circumstances you know Ronald Reagan
actually cut taxes in 1981 and it made
sense because it was basically Keynesian
stimulus for the economy in the midst of
a deep recession but now Republicans cut
taxes in 2017 even though the economy
was booming and this was only going to
be a temporary stimulus that would then
saddle us with huge deficit spending for
decades to come and that is in fact
happened but nevertheless they support
that because that is something that
basically the donors to the Republican
Party want to see and the judges is
something that the
Jellico paste the Republican Party would
like to see so out of all the ideas the
Republican Party has championed over the
decades it turns out those are the taxes
and judges are the only two that
actually matter to the Republican Party
and those are not the ideas obviously
that I've associated my career with I
want to give a chance to have some
questions from the floor we have a
microphone yes okay
so just raise your hand and the
microphone will come around and please
just introduce yourself very briefly
when you ask your question all right
we'll start out right here
hi I'm Peter Celestine a pre-doctoral
fellow at ISS here this is a question
for max Luke when you described to the
beginning the kind of conservatism that
you espoused you said that you're
suspicious of the federal government
acting as a force for good in the u.s.
so I wonder if that's so we should be
equally suspicious of the federal
government actually was a force for good
abroad we should also be suspicious of
the federal government or the United
States more broadly acting as a force
for good in the world
I think you certainly need some
skepticism of government action whether
at home or abroad I mean you know I
write in the book about the fact that
for example I you know I regret my
support for the Iraq war and I had I
think an exaggerated sense of what the
US could achieve in Iraq in terms of
transforming that country and I you know
I'm still very much a hawk and I'm still
very much a believer in American global
leadership but I am somewhat Jason and
the Iraq war certainly brought home to
me the inadvisability of a preventative
conflicts and also the limits of
military action nevertheless I still
believe and this is one thing that I
have not changed my view on I think that
the United States overall despite many
stumbles from Vietnam to Iraq I
nevertheless believe that the United
States has been the greatest force for
good in the world in the last century
and
the system that was created after World
War two by the greatest generation based
on free trade and American support for
alliances and democracy I think is very
much in our interest as well as in the
interest of the rest of the world except
of course for the despots and tyrants
out there and I think it is very much in
our interest to keep promoting that that
international system in league with our
allies and and so I think that you know
what what Trump is doing and in in in in
in coddling dictators like Kim jong-un
and Vladimir Putin and at the same time
constantly attacking allies whether the
leaders of Canada or Britain or Germany
or what-have-you
I think is highly corrosive to to the
PAC's Americana that was created after
1945 and I do believe that with all the
stumbles and all the mistakes that we've
made and God knows we've made a lot of
them I think American dominance of the
international system is far preferable
to the alternatives which are going to
be either Chinese dominance or a sheer
state of anarchy and multipolarity that
I think will be extremely dangerous and
well it could easily wind up recreated
with the pre-1914 conditions that led to
a war a global war except on a much more
dangerous scale now with the prevalence
of the proliferation of nuclear weapons
can I throw this to you as well Kim to
maybe talk about the historians
perspective so we've talked a lot about
conservatism we haven't talked about the
category of neoconservatism as much and
through the relationship between
neoconservatism and the decision to go
to war in iraq I mean I don't want to go
into a lot of detail but I want to hear
some of your reflections about that I
mean IIIi myself have actually always
had a certain discomfort or dizzy with
with the word neoconservative in
particular or rather I guess I
understand it you know the first
neoconservatives the people in the 1970s
who kind of rejected actually parts of
the free market as I fare thinking of
the right but wanted to kind of reassert
both a very idealistic anti-communist
foreign policy especially the wake of
the Vietnam War and also kind of the the
new social conservatism but so and saw
an alliance with the a certain you know
kind of tempered enthusiasm for the free
market as part of that but tried to set
themselves apart from it earlier right I
mean I think that the idea that the the
the the Iraq war though and the kind of
the idea you know in in the Iraq war the
word neoconservative the idea of the
neoconservative were people who wanted
to who saw the Iraq war and saw the
conflict or saw the possibility of
deposing Hussein as a chance to
establish democracy in the Middle East
and there's as a and describe the
foreign policy and this kind of very
idealistic very far-reaching terms and I
think you know I I II so and there is a
you know there's a group of people who
put that forward it wasn't all of the
Bush administration or everybody who
supported that war which was of course
very popular at the time her had you
know despite also having you know large
popular mobilizations against the war
and and a critique of the war and of the
entrance into the war you know from that
from the at that moment as well I think
one interesting so I I you know but but
still I think there's something about
it's not exactly
I've never praised about the term
neoconservative it got launched bobbing
around a lot it's a term of insult at
that moment without that much precision
about who was or wasn't part of it
what I do think is interesting though is
I think that the Iraq war and we I
haven't really talked that much tonight
yet really about why you know what is
the how do a if Trump doesn't come out
of the conservative movement where does
he come from or where is this
what is this about is it just a kind of
reaction to you know is that some sort
of inherent you know pre floating racism
within the American public or where does
this come from why is it happening now
and I do think that the the Iraq war
actually is an important part of that
story and kind of understanding what the
the kind of trumps appeal as a critic of
the Iraq war and as a you know the the
the the the disproportionate burdens of
the costs of the war and the kind of the
frustrations of fighting the war being
displaced towards other borders that
seem more controllable I think there is
a kind of you know there's a
relationship between the Iraq war and
the successive dropping the emergence of
trumpism and so I think that's another
you know part of the the kind of how we
got where we are now I study very the
fetching and Republican Party around the
woman's a woman's issue in the 1970s and
kind of recently I was watching a 76
speech from first last week endorsing
Reagan and when she talks about the need
to exit the salt treaty because of her
unions violating it and the US needs a
we are therefore a condemning Ford for
the terrible trade deals that caused the
massive loss of jobs overseas and either
talking about how America's being taken
over by gangs which are waiting is
murdering Americans in the thousands so
kind of and so kind of my question is to
you how do we fit first laughing and
stop er a into the lineage of American
conservatism and it's Trump in some ways
the combination of this kind of America
I mean I actually for the first time in
my life last year well I was writing
this book on the corrosion of
conservatism actually read phyllis
schlafly attract a choice not an echo
which sold millions of copies and lo and
behold in there I found an echo of
trumpism from the 1960s I mean it's
actually uncanny because this book was
utterly unhinged it was basically
suggesting that there was a conspiracy
of East Coast finance finance years who
were dominating the Republican Party and
were consciously causing the Republican
Party to lose presidential elections
because remember this was written in the
in the mid-60s after you know the the
the loss in 1964 the loss in 1960 and
then going prior to that the losses to
Harry Truman in FDR and so aside from
Eisenhower who she did not consider a
real conservative you know conservatism
had been having a pretty rough patch in
national politics and instead of saying
oh well maybe the Republican Party was
putting up unattractive candidates or
espousing unpopular views foolish laughs
lee's position was no this was an active
plot by these shade these these
eastcoast this cabal of east coast
figures who had seized control the
Republican Party and we're trying to
cause it deliberately to lose because
they were in league with Moscow and
wanted to bring communism to America
that's as crazy as it sounds but this
was actually what she believed and what
she asked what she said
and so it's kind of cop smacking to
think that with these views she became
an icon of conservatism
in the 1970s albeit in a somewhat
different context opposing the RA but
nevertheless she had these these insane
views and and they obviously echoed so
to speak with with many conservatives
who read her tract approvingly night and
I really see a straight line from people
like Phyllis Schlafly
to the kind of off the rails
conspiratorial thinking that Donald
Trump espouses I mean it's a very short
distance from what philosophy was saying
in the 60s to you know Donald Trump
suggests
that the people who have run America
prior to his ascendance didn't really
love America and they were deliberately
running us down and selling us out to
the globalists and you know Wall Street
banks and in people like George Soros
who was supposedly behind the the
caravans I mean all this kind of
insanity which taps into these long term
populist strains and American thinking
deeply suspicious of East Coast elites
of bankers of Jews of intellectuals and
they tend to link all those groups that
they hate together into one big
conspiracy not so pressing the real
Americans ie people like them
and so I think that that is a continuing
strain on the American Way which was not
part of you know intellectual
conservatism as I understood it but I
which I think has actually been in many
ways a much more powerful strain
electoral II on the right than the
actual views of people like me now I
just add that I think Shockley important
part of that into her anti feminism also
or she also saw you know it's certainly
she saw feminism as the product of a
small cabal of liberal elite
intellectual as well and and even
occasionally kind of imply that it was
connected to communism and so it so she
she had a consistent worldview but yes
it's definitely nice to see her as a
foreign policy activist first who then
came to anti feminism almost opportunist
if she kind of saw it as a new cause to
affiliate herself with but she had a you
know a strong political identity first
and I would have by the way I applaud
Kim for being suspicious of the term
neoconservatism which i think has become
largely devoid of meaning but it is
sometimes used I think actually in that
kind of conspiratorial anti-semitic
context that you see you know a
conspiracy monitoring about George Soros
and other you know other figures and I
think you know the talk about the neo
cons I'm
there's some legitimate things you can
say but I think it also became kind of a
shorthand for both the far left and the
far right tapping into this notion that
there was this cabal of Jews who are
running American foreign policy and I
think that's one of the reasons why you
need to be careful about using the term
that you don't think Barry Goldwater or
bald Reagan were overt racists or that
they were racist kind of in any real
sense of the term but you also
acknowledged that over that least the
last fifty years the Republican Party
has overwhelmingly come down on the side
against civil rights and against a lot
of what many people would say are
policies that are Pro racial equality
that are in favor of equality and
economic justice and a lot of things
that and diversity generally and I think
a lot of people would have said before
the 2016 election that there was some
kind of reckoning coming with the
Republican Party with its general lack
of diversity with this history of dog
whistling or wolf whistling to racists
and that at some point there had to be a
reckoning with that identity if
conservative ideas disassociated from
that practical legacy had to continue
and yet in 2016 as you said if anything
the dog whistling turned into wolf
listening so do you think that that
reckoning is still coming and that at
some point Republicans and the
Republican Party generally will have to
deal with this kind of racial tension
and racial history within the party and
if so how do you think that will play
out do you think there will be new
parties divisions what do you envision
for that yes I think winter is coming I
think that all those sitting here in
this frigid March day it feels like
winter is already here but no I think
look I think what happened in the past
is that Republican candidates kind of
dog-whistle to racism at election time
but by and large when you look at the
actual Republican presidents or leaders
they did not do that much to advance
this xenophobic racist agenda and I
think that caused some tension within
the party because I think there was huge
frustration that Republicans would kind
of show a little leg to racists and for
example
even George HW Bush it was fundamentally
a very decent a good person nevertheless
you know with the Willie Horton ad in
1988 kind of appealed to two racists and
then of course they were sorely
disappointed well he didn't actually do
anything to advance a racist agenda
because lo and behold he wasn't actually
a racist and so I think in some ways
Donald Trump has kind of closed the gap
between Republican campaigning and
Republican governance because in office
he's actually as racist or even more so
than any previous Republican candidate
was on the campaign trail and so this is
part of the rapturous reaction that he
has that he has received from a large
part of the Republican base and I think
in some ways he is a genius an evil
genius but he is a genius because you
know he turned kind of conventional
wisdom on its head after 2012 the
conventional wisdom was that Republicans
had to appeal to minorities and he
basically said no instead of appealing
the minorities I'm gonna double down on
white people and I'm gonna mobilize
these angry old white people who watch
Fox News and lo and behold that turned
out to be a winning strategy at least in
electoral college votes if not in
popular vote terms but at the end of the
day this is not going to succeed for the
Republican Party because by the 2040s we
are going to be a majority minority
country and the Republican Party is
increasingly identified with a shrinking
percentage of the population that is
white and what I predict will happen in
the National Republican Party is what
happened to the ruling party in my home
state of California or in the 1990s
under Pete Wilson that California
Republican Party became identified with
opposition demographics of California
the growing Latino population the
Republican Party has been wiped out in
California there's not a single
statewide office holder and out of the
entire congressional delegation of
something like 56 Congress people I
think there's like seven Republicans
something like that tiny minority and so
I think this is the fate that awaits the
Republican Party on this trumpian course
but that doesn't mean that Trump can't
conceivably squeeze out another victory
with his angry old white people base in
2020 and of course by the time the
Republican Party is destroyed at some
point in the future
Trump is going to be gone from office
and what does he care he's
not a really Republican anyway thing to
that which is I think I do think that
it's um how to put this I I just I just
think that there's something tricky
about sort of just referring to the
Tom's popularity solely or completely in
terms of these sort of the racist appeal
or there is like a kind of group of
people who are the define racists in
American history and it's competing I
just I just I'm not sure that that's
quite the right framework and I think in
some ways these you know so for example
they're just thinking about the where
are these these policies where these
politics come from or thinking about the
Omega Administration on the one hand
Reagan with immigration you know there
are these very idealistic sort of
sweeping statements about immigration at
the same time it's also during the
Reagan years that you start to see the
militarization of the border in a new
way with the drug war you start to see
the emergence of a you know you see the
revival of a rhetoric of a crisis of
immigration especially with regard to
the Cuban the the Mariel boatlift and
the sense of it being a Haitian if an
emergency of Haitian immigrants who are
then kind of a policy of intercepting
Haitians immigrants it see so there's a
a and and a and that's also when you
start to see the growth of detention as
a policy for people in the country
illegally and so I think it's a you know
it's not there's just a kind of deeper
reservoir for these policies it's not
just you know kind of a and reckoning
with them doesn't just mean sort of
confronting over statements of racism or
prejudice but it means grappling with a
whole you know a kind of a policy
framework to that is then the basis out
of which these ideas emerge so and and
and and take hold and become you know
kind of meaningful parts of a parts of
people to live reality so anyway I just
I just think it's a larger you know I
would just kind of
I think you have to expand the framework
somewhat great I think we have time if
there are a last couple of questions we
can bundle together and then get some
some reflections up here take this one
down here if there's anyone else and
over there as well okay we'll do these
three I wonder if you think there was
any hope for me I continue to be and I
know there shouldn't be a political
discussion and I'm taking the risk of
being close to it
I've been registered Republican for the
last 50 years in my age of 88 years I
graduated from Yale in 1953 and I tell
my friends who are all Democrats because
they're more fun and I like a lot of
their attitudes that the reason I'm a
registered Republican is hoping that I
can bring the Republican Party back to
its senses and that I want fiscal
conservatism which is compatible with
being progressive in terms of civic
matters is there any hope for me yes
well I mean I think yeah I mean I I
guess if I were if we were having a
longer conversation I would want to know
what you're not kind of what what you
associate with fiscal responsibility
what does it mean to be fiscally
responsible one no deficits at its heart
well certainly I mean I don't know I'm
not sure what you'll do in terms of your
vote for but I think the politics you
know I also I mean I I wouldn't I I
don't right yeah i but I think I think
that the the the you know the deficits
III agree that we have that people have
to think about where the money to pay
for social programs will come from and
what it means to to have I I guess I
would maybe draw the lines differently
but I also I know I think that the basic
principle of funding a that you have to
be able to fund the social programs that
you want to see exist
is an important one and I don't think it
yeah I think you know people who want to
see a broader social safety net a
broader welfare state a broader
distribution of social resources have to
think about where that will come from so
it's not I don't think you can do it out
of thin air or magic or simply running a
deficit forever and ever so I think that
that's a I think it's an important
question and I think it's it's you know
I don't know what you'll do in terms of
who to vote for or how to handle those
questions but I think well have good
parties I don't think you know I it's
not I and again I don't know if I would
ruin entirely about frugality look let
me get these last there's last question
over here and was there okay we'll take
this let's bundle them together get all
three questions over there here and then
down front and then we'll we'll get some
final thoughts and wrap them so don't
answer until we heard all the questions
I'll be I'll be brief as almost a banana
jam
postdoc here with ISS now I want to come
back to the very first question that we
had
which to me was really a question about
American force projection conservative
interests in force projection by the
Americans and you make the American
government and its desire not to have
this force being checked I prefer I did
this questions for my beliefs I'd like
to hear your thoughts on this on your
numerous columns oh yeah I'm on North
Korea I worked myself in your weapons
and your proliferation and I'm curious
as to where we could go so when I read
you what I read is we need to go back to
maximum sanction what we've done before
to try and get them to fold but it seems
that the other side of the aisle is an
immutable force that is very cognizant
of what happened to the Gaddafi and
Hussein of this world and have
absolutely no desire to denuclearize and
it seems that the system the US desire
to get them to denuclearize as one of
force projection layered unto threat
management and my question although out
of all this is what's wrong with the
Tarrance why can we can we stop dealing
with North Korea is a non-proliferation
question and turn to this as an arms
control question and really try to
settle the problem what's wrong or is
American force projections calculation
makes it impossible to flip the question
the way that I okay great
we have a question here as well
hi Emily Whelan I'm a pre docket ISS
really light topic um I wanted to return
to the question of anti-semitism and
support for Israel because it seems that
this is an issue that sort of transcends
the parsing between the sort of
intellectual nevertrump errs and the
very anti-semitic pro-trump errs which
is generally both tend to land on the
side of supporting Israel so I'm
wondering if we could talk a little bit
about the way that the relationship
between the United States and Israel
kind of moves forward on the sort of
conservative side of things Thanks I
wanted to direct my question
specifically to mr. boot I wanted to ask
about your comments on what commentators
called the liberal international order
like the system set up post 45 and
crystallized after the Cold War because
you said that you believed that this was
the best system with the u.s. at its
helm but right now we're seeing a lot of
emerging illiberal powers making a sort
of inroads around the world and so I'm
wondering if you see the best strategy
for American foreign policy to be
doubling down on be on on being this
proactive global power maintaining its I
guess hegemony or if you see a better if
given the current context of the where
we see ourselves in the liberal
international order do you see an
alternative foreign policy as being
better well why don't you start out with
the specific questions they were mostly
directed to you and then we'll give you
a chance for a few final okay a lot of
things to consider
okay North Korea you know Donald Trump
is clearly laboring under some elaborate
delusion if he thinks that Kim jong-un
is in love with him or is going to give
up his nuclear weapons not going to
happen the US intelligence community is
right he's not going to give up the
nuclear weapons the reason I think we
don't have a lot of good options and in
North Korea if we continue having
summits with them legitimating him
undercutting sanctions as Trump is doing
calling the u.s. South Korea alliance
and the question by canceling military
exercises we are basically empowering
Kim Jong on even as he continues to
build more nuclear weapons even as he
continues to build more ballistic
missiles I think the policy of maximal
pressure and sanctions is only is very
it was really only applied in 2016-2017
and clearly the North Koreans don't like
it because they're desperate for those
sanctions to be lifted so I don't I
don't I'm you know I don't mind talking
to the North Koreans but I don't believe
in making unilateral concessions when
they're not willing to even freeze their
nuclear program which they clearly are
not at this point so I think we just
need to continue with the policy of
maximum pressure as well as with
deterrence I mean remember that
deterrence worked with the Soviet Union
for decades and they had a lot more
nuclear weapons than North Korea does I
don't think that North Korea is going to
attack us or South Korea with nuclear
weapons as long as we have 28,000
American troops there as long as we have
the American nuclear umbrella so
pressure and deterrence I think it
they're not like a magic solution
they're not going to make North Korea
the North Korean problem go away but I
think that's the best way to manage the
problem then we had another question
here about the u.s. relational
relationship with Israel and you know
it's kind of bizarre because Donald
Trump appeals you know he says that you
know white supremacists are good people
and he appeals to a lot of very
disreputable elements on the right but
he also has a fair amount of support in
the American Jewish community because he
is so pro-israel and I'm sympathetic to
things like moving the US Embassy to
Jerusalem because in fact you're Aslam
is the capital of Israel but what I you
know I think that Trump is going too far
in giving Benjamin Netanyahu a blank
check and in fact Bibi is kind of the
Israeli version of Trump utterly amoral
pursuing his own self-interest making
disreputable alliances with far-right
parties in in Israel as well as in
Europe and elsewhere and at the end of
the day I don't think that actually
Donald Trump is going to be good for the
Jews because I think what Donald Trump
is doing is he is hyper politicizing
American support for Israel he is
turning it into a political football and
there Israel's the Israeli US Alliance
for much of its history has been has
enjoyed bipartisan support and you saw
some of that even fading before Donald
Trump came along because I think there
is more sympathy on the left side of the
political spectrum for Palestinians you
see it with congresswoman
Omar who is not only sympathetic to
Palestinians but in fact says things
that are widely and rightly denounced as
anti-semitic I think she's still a very
marginal voice on the left but look at
what happened with the Labour Party in
the UK with Jeremy Corbyn where he has
institutionalized hostility to Israel in
anti-semitism I think those are very
dangerous trends and I don't we're not
necessarily going to go there but I
think what Donald Trump is doing is very
deleterious to Israel's long-term
security because he is really rooting
support for Israel among a fringe of the
American right and what you know what
happens when Republicans are not in
power in the future you're going to
Israel is going to have an a democratic
administration which is probably going
to be a lot less sympathetic to Israel
especially if Netanyahu is in power then
previous Democratic administrations were
and the final question was about
American you know grant strategy going
forward I guess appropriately enough in
this forum and I do think that the best
American grand strategy is the same one
that we have been pursuing since
arguably let's say 1942 which is to
create a pox Americana in concert with
our allies and basically to support this
this alliance system of American allies
whether it's Japan South Korea Australia
in newer allies like Vietnam or India or
Indonesia and Asia or NATO and our
European allies to support those allies
and also to support the cause of free
trade even if it cost us you know a
little bit of a trade deficit in the
short run it actually creates greater
opportunities for the entire world and I
think this system of American alliances
in free trade has really underwritten
the greatest expansion of peace and
prosperity in human history the longest
period without a great power conflict
and I think that is what we need to
continue doing I think there is actually
a lot of hunger for that now because you
know even though people are deeply
suspicious of America under Trump and
rightly so our soft I mean he is
engaging in unilateral soft power
disarmament to a shocking degree but
nevertheless people still want the
United States to be this kind of
benevolent hedge
want to be this balancer against local
bullies whether it's Russia and Europe
or China and Asia all those countries
are looking to America to balance these
illiberal rising powers and their
neighborhoods that threaten their own
sovereignty and so I think there is a
need and a desire for America to
continue leading what used to be known
as the free world but I think it's
becoming harder and harder because I
think people are losing confidence in
America the longer that Donald Trump is
in power because you know he is so
hostile to this American system of
security alliances and free trade we've
never had a president since 1945 so
hostile to the underpinnings of American
power and the bipartisan foreign policy
in trade policy that administration
after administration has pursued since
the days of very true yeah I think it
would be I I think I would make the case
that there's actually a deeper
skepticism about the benevolence of
American power in much of the world and
that that is you know perhaps is is that
so that the I guess yeah maybe it's a
sense you think the crisis is a crisis
of the Pax Americana or the conservative
movement or is there a kind of a broader
crisis which is what this moment is
coming out of and I think that too I so
I'm not sure that that yeah I guess I'm
not sure that simply shoring up what
existed before is either possible or
adequate as a solution to the problems
that we confront going forward both
domestically and internationally
lately ominous note if that would be the
task of the generation of people who are
sitting here to figure that figure that
all thank you max boot and Kim Phillips
fine for this fascinating come
sation and to all of you for
participating
[Applause]
[Music]